This episode is brought to you by Accenture. When your advertising operations fall out of sync, everything else follows. Spotify and Accenture are working together to reinvent the rhythm of ad sales, using automation, analytics, and smarter workflows to simplify campaign delivery and access better data across the business. The result? Less time spent on operations, more time connecting brands with the moments and fandoms that matter most. Learn more at Accenture.com slash Spotify.
本期节目由埃森哲（Accenture）赞助播出。当您的广告运营失去同步时，其他一切都会随之受到影响。Spotify 和埃森哲正在携手重塑广告销售的节奏，利用自动化、分析和更智能的工作流程来简化广告活动的投放，并获取整个业务中更优质的数据。结果如何？减少了运营耗时，腾出更多时间将品牌与最重要的时刻和粉丝群体联系起来。欲了解更多信息，请访问 Accenture.com/Spotify。
Too often, we treat sleep as a luxury rather than a necessity. It's something we sacrifice when life gets busy, but even as the world makes it harder to prioritize sleep, psychologists and other researchers are finding increasing evidence that sleep is critical to our mental and physical health. They're also finding that addressing sleep problems may be an effective and underused way to treat mental health disorders. So what exactly happens in the sleeping brain? Why does a bad night's sleep affect our mood so profoundly? How are sleep and circadian rhythms connected to mental health? What have researchers learned about using sleep-based interventions to treat mental health disorders?
我们往往将睡眠视为一种奢侈品，而非必需品。当生活变得忙碌时，我们就会牺牲睡眠。然而，尽管当今世界让人们越来越难以优先考虑睡眠，但心理学家和其他研究人员发现，越来越多的证据表明，睡眠对我们的身心健康至关重要。他们还发现，解决睡眠问题可能是治疗心理健康障碍的一种有效且未被充分利用的方法。那么，处于睡眠状态的大脑究竟发生了什么？为什么糟糕的睡眠会如此深刻地影响我们的情绪？睡眠和昼夜节律与心理健康有何关联？研究人员在利用基于睡眠的干预措施治疗心理健康障碍方面学到了什么？
And what can all of us do to get enough good quality sleep in a world that seems designed to disrupt it? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Philip German, a professor of clinical psychology and psychiatry at the University of Pennsylvania, where he directs the sleep neurobiology and psychopathology lab. His research focuses on sleep, circadian rhythms, and mental health, including the role that sleep disturbances play in mental health disorders and the development of new treatments
在这样一个似乎旨在破坏睡眠的世界里，我们所有人又能做些什么来获得充足且高质量的睡眠呢？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会（APA）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是宾夕法尼亚大学临床心理学和精神病学教授菲利普·格曼（Philip German）博士，他在那里负责睡眠神经生物学和精神病理学实验室。他的研究重点是睡眠、昼夜节律和心理健康，包括睡眠障碍在心理健康障碍中的作用以及新疗法的开发。
for insomnia and other sleep problems. He has published extensively in leading academic journals, and his work has been covered in media outlets, including Time Magazine and The Washington Post. He recently spoke with APA's magazine Monitor on Psychology for an article on the New Science of Sleep. Dr. German, thank you for joining me today. Thanks so much for having me. Let's start with the big picture. Why is sleep so important for our health and our mental health and what's happening in the brain while we're asleep that helps us function while we're awake? The short answer is there's a lot. We know that sleep plays so many critical roles for healthy brain functioning. So it's tied to our motion regulations
针对失眠和其他睡眠问题。他在领先的学术期刊上发表了大量文章，他的工作也受到了《时代》杂志和《华盛顿邮报》等媒体的报道。他最近接受了美国心理学会旗下杂志《心理学监测》（Monitor on Psychology）的采访，谈论了关于睡眠的新科学。格曼博士，感谢您今天参加我的节目。非常感谢您的邀请。让我们从大局谈起。为什么睡眠对我们的健康和心理健康如此重要？在我们睡觉时，大脑中发生了什么，从而帮助我们在清醒时正常运作？简短的回答是，发生了很多事情。我们知道，睡眠对大脑的健康运作起着许多关键作用。它与我们的情绪调节
abilities, it's tied even to the clearance of waste products from the brain. So there's just a lot happening during sleep that is critical for a healthy brain functioning. Now, sleep problems are often seen as a symptom of depression, anxiety, or other mental health disorders, but your research suggests that sleep can be a cause, not just a consequence of mental health problems. How has our understanding of the relationship between sleep and mental health changed in recent years? Yeah, this is something the sleep field has been trying to change for a very long time, because as you said, it's just been assumed by the mental health field that when people have insomnia, you don't really need to pay attention to the insomnia or the other sleep problems.
能力有关，甚至与大脑中废弃物的清除有关。因此，在睡眠期间发生了很多对大脑健康运作至关重要的事情。现在，睡眠问题通常被视为抑郁症、焦虑症或其他心理健康障碍的症状，但您的研究表明，睡眠可能是心理健康问题的原因，而不仅仅是结果。近年来，我们对睡眠与心理健康之间关系的理解发生了怎样的变化？是的，这是睡眠领域长期以来一直试图改变的事情，因为正如你所说，心理健康领域一直认为，当人们失眠时，你并不真正需要关注失眠或其他睡眠问题。
you just have to focus on their depression, on their anxiety, on their psychosis, whatever it may be. But there's now several dozen longitudinal studies showing that for people who don't meet the criteria for any mental health problems, if they have trouble sleeping, they're roughly two to three times more likely to go on to develop depression, anxiety, substance use disorder. So poor sleep can actually be a risk factor increasing vulnerability to poor mental health. And is that being taught in schools right now? Well, most mental health providers, regardless of discipline, get virtually no education about sleep in their graduate school curriculum, despite the fact that we spend a third of our lives doing it.
你只需要专注于他们的抑郁、焦虑、精神病，无论是什么。但现在有几十项纵向研究表明，对于那些不符合任何心理健康问题标准的人来说，如果他们有睡眠困难，他们患上抑郁症、焦虑症、药物滥用障碍的可能性大约是普通人的两到三倍。因此，睡眠质量差实际上可能是一个增加心理健康脆弱性的风险因素。目前学校里有教授这些内容吗？嗯，大多数心理健康提供者，无论学科如何，在他们的研究生课程中几乎没有接受过关于睡眠的教育，尽管我们一生中有三分之一的时间都在睡觉。
And so we're trying to increase the education that's out there. But unfortunately, most people just aren't getting much of anything. So what are the implications of this new research for psychologists and other mental health clinicians? It really opens up our toolbox for a range of different options. And so, you know, I'm always trying to teach mental health providers to pay attention to sleep, to listen to what their clients are telling them about their sleep and to try to figure out are their specific sleep disorders going on. And if there are, the good news is we have effective treatments for a number of them. So bringing that sleep focus in can take a more holistic approach to someone's mental health and provide access to a whole new set of techniques that they can bring to bear on treating someone's mental health problems. Now, you talked a little bit about how the brain sort of goes through a cleaning process while we sleep.
所以我们正在努力增加这方面的教育。但不幸的是，大多数人并没有得到多少相关知识。那么，这项新研究对心理学家和其他心理健康临床医生有什么启示呢？它确实为我们提供了一系列不同的选择。所以，你知道，我一直在教导心理健康提供者要关注睡眠，倾听客户关于睡眠的诉求，并试图找出他们是否存在特定的睡眠障碍。如果有的话，好消息是我们有针对其中许多问题的有效治疗方法。因此，引入这种对睡眠的关注可以采取更全面的方法来处理某人的心理健康，并提供一套全新的技术，他们可以将其应用于治疗某人的心理健康问题。现在，你谈到大脑在睡眠时会经历一种清洁过程。
And I'm wondering, how does that relate to inflammation? in the body, something that we now know is the cause of numerous physical ailments. This has been a really hot area of research the last six or seven years in the field where it was discovered that it's during sleep, that waste products that just normally build up from waking brain function, it's during sleep that they're cleared away, in particular our deep sleep. And the waste product that has been studied the most is the protein beta amyloid, which is of course thought to play a role in risk for Alzheimer's disease. And so, for example, one night of total sleep deprivation in healthy individuals is associated with a 20% increase of this protein in the brain.
我想知道，这与体内的炎症有什么关系？我们现在知道炎症是导致多种身体疾病的原因。这是过去六七年来该领域非常热门的研究领域，人们发现正是在睡眠期间，由清醒大脑功能正常积累的废弃物才会被清除，特别是在深度睡眠期间。研究最多的废弃物是β-淀粉样蛋白，它当然被认为在阿尔茨海默病的风险中起作用。因此，例如，健康个体经历一晚完全的睡眠剥夺与大脑中这种蛋白质增加20%有关。
And so we're now thinking that chronically not getting a good night of sleep actually increases risk for dementia. Now, there is some evidence that inflammation may be one of the pathways for these associations. We know that difficulty sleeping is associated with increased inflammation, and so there's a lot of research. It's a very hot area of research right now. Well, let's talk about insomnia, which you just alluded to. How common is it and how does it affect people's mental health over time? Chronic insomnia, meaning someone who's been having insomnia for three months or longer, is about 10 to 15 percent of the U.S. population. but about another 25 to 35% of people experience bouts of insomnia here and there,
所以我们现在认为，长期无法获得良好的睡眠实际上会增加患痴呆症的风险。现在，有一些证据表明炎症可能是这些关联的途径之一。我们知道睡眠困难与炎症增加有关，所以有很多研究。这目前是一个非常热门的研究领域。那么，让我们谈谈你刚才提到的失眠。它有多普遍？随着时间的推移，它如何影响人们的心理健康？慢性失眠，即某人失眠持续三个月或更长时间，约占美国人口的10%到15%。但另外约25%到35%的人会时不时地经历失眠，
but maybe not continuous to the point where we would say, well, this is a chronic problem. So if you add those up, it's roughly a third to a half of U.S. adults are experiencing insomnia to at least some degree. It's a huge problem. And as far as the impact on mental health, I often say there's kind of two components to that. What is the next day effects? So when I ask people, when you have not had a good night asleep, how does that affect you during the day? And one of the most common things I hear is, I'm irritable, I'm grouchy. And so there's the toll that it takes on just how you feel the next day in terms of your
但可能没有持续到我们称之为慢性问题的程度。所以如果你把这些加起来，大约三分之一到一半的美国成年人在某种程度上正在经历失眠。这是一个巨大的问题。至于对心理健康的影响，我常说这有两个组成部分。一个是次日的影响。所以当我问人们，当你没有睡好时，这在白天如何影响你？我听到的最常见的事情之一是，我很烦躁，我很暴躁。所以这会对你第二天在
emotional and mental functioning, difficulty concentrating, attention, things like that. Then there's the chronic issues. As I mentioned before, the fact that chronic insomnia can increase the likelihood of the of developing new onset mental health conditions or worsening pre-existing conditions. So what effective treatments do we have right now for chronic insomnia? So there's two main evidence-based approaches. There is the medication approach. And I always say the pros and cons of the medications are pros. They're widely available. There's a number of them to choose from. Cons are, the average effects are quite small, we're quite modest.
情绪和心理功能、注意力集中、专注力等方面产生影响。然后是慢性问题。正如我之前提到的，慢性失眠实际上会增加患上新发心理健康疾病或加重既有疾病的可能性。那么我们目前有什么有效的慢性失眠治疗方法呢？主要有两种基于证据的方法。一种是药物治疗方法。我总是说药物的利弊是：优点是它们广泛可用，有很多选择。缺点是，平均效果相当小，相当温和。
And so people often say, well, I sleep a little bit better with the medication, but still not great, and their effects can wear off over time. As a psychologist, what I practice is cognitive behavioral therapy for insomnia, or what we call CBTI, for short, which has decades of clinical trials evidence backing up its efficacy. And it's a fairly short-term treatment, as far as psychotherapies go, typically six to eight sessions, where we're teaching, people, a variety of techniques, I call it sleep retraining. We're teaching people how to break the cycle of insomnia and retrain their body into a healthy pattern of sleep again. And the pros are a good success rate. The improvements are generally maintained over time. The main disadvantage is it's obviously more work than medications. It's very easy to pop a pill, but people have to invest the time and energy into doing CBTI. I want to talk
所以人们经常说，嗯，我吃药后睡得好一点，但仍然不是很好，而且它们的效果会随着时间的推移而减弱。作为一名心理学家，我实践的是失眠认知行为疗法，简称CBTI，它有几十年的临床试验证据支持其疗效。就心理治疗而言，这是一种相当短期的治疗，通常为六到八次疗程，我们教人们各种技术，我称之为睡眠再训练。我们教人们如何打破失眠的循环，并将他们的身体重新训练成健康的睡眠模式。优点是成功率高。改善通常能长期保持。主要缺点是它显然比药物治疗需要更多的工作。吃药很容易，但人们必须投入时间和精力来做CBTI。我想谈谈
about one of the more surprising findings in sleep research, which is that sleep deprivation can sometimes have an antidepressant effect. This seems counterintuitive. Maybe you can tell us a little bit more about this research that you have conducted. So counterintuitive is exactly the word that I use. It is, to my knowledge, the only potentially beneficial effect of sleep deprivation. and sometimes we call therapeutic sleep deprivation or people have also used the term wake therapy which sounds not as bad as therapeutic sleep deprivation but there's decades of research showing
睡眠研究中一个更令人惊讶的发现，即睡眠剥夺有时会产生抗抑郁作用。这似乎违反直觉。也许你可以告诉我们更多关于你所进行的这项研究。所以“违反直觉”正是我想用的词。据我所知，这是睡眠剥夺唯一潜在的有益效果。有时我们称之为治疗性睡眠剥夺，或者人们也使用“觉醒疗法”这个词，听起来不像治疗性睡眠剥夺那么糟糕，但有几十年的研究表明
that one night of total sleep deprivation is associated with improvement of depression in about 50% of individuals and so prior to some of the newer research on things like ketamine, it was long been known as the fastest antidepressant response that we have. Now, the disadvantage of it is that typically when people go back to sleep, their depression returns. So it has very rapid effects, but not very sustained effects.
一晚完全的睡眠剥夺与约50%的个体抑郁症的改善有关。因此，在一些关于氯胺酮等药物的新研究出现之前，它长期以来一直被称为我们拥有的最快的抗抑郁反应。现在，它的缺点是，通常当人们重新入睡时，他们的抑郁症就会复发。所以它有非常迅速的效果，但效果并不持久。
And you say it only happens to about 50% of people who are studied. So I'm wondering, what is the difference in these two cohorts? Yeah, and that's what research has been, including our own, has been trying to figure out, is how can we figure out who is going to respond to sleep deprivation and who isn't? And so we did some research looking for neuroimaging markers, and we found some patterns of connectivity in the brain that had some predictive ability to see who was going to do well. There's some theories out there that depending on people's biological rhythms,
你说它只发生在约50%的研究对象身上。所以我想知道，这两个群体有什么区别？是的，这正是包括我们在内的研究一直试图弄清楚的问题，即我们如何找出谁会对睡眠剥夺产生反应，谁不会？因此，我们做了一些寻找神经影像标记的研究，我们发现大脑中一些连接模式具有一定的预测能力，可以看到谁会表现良好。有一些理论认为，根据人们的生物节律，
that that might predict whether they respond. Subtypes of depression may respond better than others. And so it's still a bit of a mystery, but people have for years tried to figure out what's different about these people who respond. So it doesn't sound like something that your therapist will necessarily tell you to go home and stay up all night and you'll feel better, right? Absolutely. And I hope no one listening to this takes away that they should go home and sleep deprive themselves or slav or tell their patients to do that. Because when it is done, it's done in controlled, highly monitored settings. Now, your work focuses quite a bit on sleep and circadian rhythms. Can you explain for listeners what circadian rhythms are and why they matter for mental health? Circadian rhythms are the daily
这可能预测他们是否会有反应。抑郁症的亚型可能比其他亚型反应更好。所以这仍然是一个谜，但多年来人们一直试图弄清楚这些有反应的人有什么不同。所以这听起来不像你的治疗师一定会让你回家熬夜，然后你就会感觉更好，对吧？绝对不是。我希望听到这个节目的任何人不要认为他们应该回家剥夺自己的睡眠，或者告诉他们的病人这样做。因为当它被执行时，是在受控、高度监测的环境中进行的。现在，你的工作相当多地关注睡眠和昼夜节律。你能为听众解释一下什么是昼夜节律，以及为什么它们对心理健康很重要吗？昼夜节律是每日
approximately 24-hour rhythms in our body. And what we've learned is that just about everything in our biology follows a daily rhythm. So our body temperature has a very strong circadian or daily rhythm. The levels of the different hormones in our body cycle in a 24-hour rhythm. Even our DNA, about two-thirds of our genome, is transcribed in a circadian fashion. And we know the circadian rhythms are present in humans all the way down to single-celled organisms. So they're just a central aspect of life. And they really just help to keep our body in sync with the environment around us, but also what we call internally synchronized, meaning the different parts of our body are all in sync with each other. So we know that when people
大约24小时的身体节律。我们了解到，我们生物学中的几乎所有事物都遵循每日节律。所以我们的体温有非常强的昼夜节律。我们体内不同激素的水平以24小时的节律循环。甚至我们的DNA，约三分之二的基因组，都是以昼夜节律方式转录的。我们知道昼夜节律存在于人类身上，一直到单细胞生物。所以它们只是生命的一个核心方面。它们确实有助于保持我们的身体与周围环境同步，但也保持我们所说的内部同步，意味着我们身体的不同部分都彼此同步。所以我们知道，当人们
have disturbed circadian rhythms, it can also be a risk factor for poor mental health. And one of the more common ways in which this happens is people who are night owls. It's 10 to 15% of the population is a night owl, and it's hard for them to fall asleep until later. at night, hard for them to wake up early in the morning, which is fine unless you have responsibilities that mean you have to be up early. Our culture does not revolve around the night schedule. So you have these night owls who are being forced to live on a morning person's schedule in that mismatch can have detrimental effects on our mental health. And of course, the same thing happens to people who work shifts. I mean, for years when I was a reporter, I was on a night shift,
昼夜节律紊乱时，这也可能成为心理健康不佳的风险因素。发生这种情况的常见方式之一是人们是“夜猫子”。10%到15%的人口是夜猫子，他们很难在晚上晚些时候入睡，很难在早上早起，这没问题，除非你有责任意味着你必须早起。我们的文化并不围绕夜间时间表运转。所以你有这些被迫生活在早起者时间表上的夜猫子，这种不匹配会对我们的心理健康产生有害影响。当然，轮班工作的人也会发生同样的情况。我的意思是，多年来当我是一名记者时，我是在夜班，
I was on an overnight shift, and I felt crummy the whole time. I mean, can you reset your circadian rhythm? And if so, how long does it take to do that? Yeah, about almost one in four workers in the U.S. is a shift worker. It's a huge problem. And you're absolutely right. It just wrecks havoc on our circadian rhythms. A lot of people, if they come off the night shift and they kind of go back on a day's schedule,
我是在通宵班，我一直感觉很糟糕。我的意思是，你能重置你的昼夜节律吗？如果可以，需要多长时间才能做到？是的，美国几乎四分之一的工人是轮班工人。这是一个巨大的问题。你说得完全正确。它只是破坏了我们的昼夜节律。很多人，如果他们下夜班，他们会回到白天的日程安排，
you know, within a few weeks or so, sometimes even faster, their circadian rhythms will readjust to the day's schedule. However, there are some people, and these are some of the people I see in the sleep clinic where I practice, even years later, their bodies have not readjusted. They seem to get stuck on a night schedule. And so we're often using certain kind of treatment approaches to try to re-synchronize their rhythms to a day schedule. You know, I've met people who say that they're fine with five or six hours of sleep. And I've been reading lately that the whole, you know, you have to have seven to eight hours of sleep is being questioned.
你知道，在几周左右，有时甚至更快，他们的昼夜节律会重新调整到白天的日程安排。然而，有些人，这些人是我在执业的睡眠诊所里看到的一些人，即使多年后，他们的身体也没有重新调整。他们似乎被困在夜间时间表上。所以我们经常使用某种治疗方法来尝试将他们的节律重新同步到白天的时间表。你知道，我见过有人说他们睡五六个小时就够了。我最近读到，整个“你必须睡七到八个小时”的说法正在受到质疑。
Do we know what the optimal amount of sleep is for most human beings? It's a difficult question to answer for a couple of reasons. One, most of the research we have is based on people's reports of how many hours of sleep that they get. And we know that we're actually pretty bad at judging how much we've slept at night sometimes. But it is certainly the case that based on epidemiological. research and experimental research, that seven to eight hours seems to be optimal for most people, although some need less and some need more. But the other problem is that we've developed almost, I often say it's almost an obsessive focus on sleep quantity. Everybody, oh, how many hours
我们知道大多数人类的最佳睡眠量是多少吗？这是一个很难回答的问题，原因有二。第一，我们拥有的大多数研究都是基于人们对自己睡眠时长的报告。我们知道，有时我们实际上很不擅长判断自己晚上睡了多少。但可以肯定的是，基于流行病学研究和实验研究，七到八小时对大多数人来说似乎是最佳的，尽管有些人需要更少，有些人需要更多。但另一个问题是，我们几乎发展出了一种，我常说这几乎是对睡眠数量的强迫性关注。每个人都问，“你昨晚睡了几个小时？”在我看来，我们没有给予人们获得的睡眠质量足够的关注。所以你晚上可以睡八或九个小时，但如果睡眠质量差，你白天仍然不会感到休息。所以这是一个找到数量和质量的正确组合的问题。我们要休息一下。回来后，我将与格曼博士讨论像Oura戒指等消费者睡眠追踪器如何改变人们对什么是良好睡眠的看法。如今，我们很多人都有一直佩戴的追踪器，无论是戒指、手表还是其他电子设备，它们都会告诉你你的睡眠情况。
did you sleep last night? In my opinion, we don't pay enough attention to the quality of sleep that people are getting. And so you can get eight or nine hours of sleep at night, but if it's poor quality sleep, you're still not going to feel rested during the day. So it's a matter of finding the right combination of quantity and quality. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk with Dr. German about how consumer sleep trackers like aura rings and others are changing people's attitudes about what constitutes a good night's sleep. Nowadays, a lot of us have trackers that we wear all the time, whether it's or a ring or a watch or, you know, other electronics that will tell you how you're sleeping.
我知道我的戒指有时告诉我我的睡眠质量很差，但我早上起床时感觉很好。那么这些设备是如何改变我们对待睡眠的方式的呢？这只是让我们感到焦虑吗？对某些人来说，绝对是。你知道，我得到的最常见的问题之一是我无法很好地回答，那就是这些设备的准确性如何。因为，你知道，我们一直在使用这些设备，我的意思是，我第一次参与睡眠研究是在1995年，我想，我们当时已经在用这些设备了。但我们使用的是研究级设备，有发表的验证研究，它们用来估计睡眠和清醒的算法是公开的，所以我们确切地知道它们在做什么。
I know my ring has told me that I've had poor quality sleep some nights and I get up in the morning and I feel fine. So how are these devices changing how we approach sleep? Is it just making us anxious? For some people, absolutely. you know, one of the most common questions I get that I can't answer very well is how accurate are these devices. Because, you know, we've been using these devices for, I mean, I first got involved in sleep research in, I guess it was 1995, and we were already using these devices. But we use research-grade devices where there are published validation studies, the algorithms they're using to estimate sleep and wake are published, so we know exactly what they're doing.
大多数人现在拥有的是这种我们称之为消费者可穿戴设备的激增，公司通常不发表验证研究，不发表他们的算法，当然他们一直在调整他们的算法。所以我们真的不知道它们有多准确。对于消费者可穿戴设备来说，似乎确实存在的情况是，它们可能与研究设备具有相同的模式，即它们在睡眠良好的人身上往往更准确。因为如果你考虑当人们失眠时会发生什么，我的意思是，这些设备使用的主要传感器之一是测量运动。嗯，失眠的人躺在床上不动，但仍然清醒。这些设备往往会将其高估为睡眠。所以你睡得越差，这些设备可能就越不准确。让我抓狂的是，当我的客户进来时，他们说出你刚才说的话，你知道，我以为我昨晚睡得很好，但我的可穿戴设备说我没有。所以因此，我没有睡好。他们将其视为绝对真理。所以我总是告诉人们要对它们持保留态度。当然，已经有一些发表的研究涉及同事所称的“正交睡眠症”（orthosomnia），即人们因为佩戴这些设备而产生失眠。他们对睡眠产生了这种强迫性的关注，这实际上使他们的睡眠变得更糟。所以你在实验室里使用的技术与你从智能手表中可能获得的技术非常不同。我的意思是，你所观察到的与你说的这些戒指等等有什么不同？它们测量你是否在移动。你做的有什么不同？物理观察人们在实验室睡觉，这就是区别吗？所以当人们来到睡眠实验室时，或者我应该说，我们现在经常在人们家里做这件事。我目前的研究几乎都在人们家里进行，我们正在监测他们的大脑活动，所以是脑电图（EEG）。一个重要的区别是所有的可穿戴设备，它们实际上并没有测量
What most people have is now this proliferation of these what we call consumer wearables, where the companies typically don't publish validation studies, they don't publish their algorithms, and of course they're always tweaking their algorithms. So we really don't know how accurate they are. What does seem to be the case for the consumer wearables is that they may have the same pattern as the research devices, which is that they tend to be more accurate in people. who sleep well. Because if you think about what happens when people have insomnia, I mean, one of the main sensors that these devices is using is they're measuring movement. Well, people
睡眠。它们测量运动、心率、皮肤温度，取决于它们包含什么传感器。它们利用这些信息来估计睡眠和清醒。直接测量睡眠的唯一方法是测量大脑活动。所以当人们来到睡眠实验室，或者如果我们在家里研究他们，我们会给他们接上所有这些电极来测量直接的大脑活动，作为对他们睡眠情况更可靠的指标。大多数人至少偶尔会经历睡眠质量差的时期。你如何区分轻微的睡眠问题和应该寻求帮助的问题？可能最大的因素是它持续了多久。
with insomnia lie awake in bed still, but still awake. And these devices tend to overestimate that as sleep. And that's, so the worst you sleep, probably the less accurate these devices are. And it, what drives me crazy, is when my clients come in and they say exactly what you say, you know, I thought I slept well last night, but my wearable said I did it. So therefore, I did not. And they treat it as absolute truth. And so I always tell people to take them with a grain of salt. And there certainly, there have been some published studies of what a colleague has termed orthosomnia, where people are developing insomnia because of wearing these devices. They're developing this obsessive focus on
我的意思是，就像你说的，我们所有人都会时不时地经历失眠。有时当我和观众交谈时，我会问，如果你从未睡过一个糟糕的夜晚，请举手。从来没有人举手。对。所以，你知道，我绝对想正常化偶尔睡个糟糕的夜晚是完全正常的。但当它持续了几周，变成几个月，而且就是不消失时。
their sleep, and it's actually making their sleep worse. So the techniques that you would be using in the lab that are very different from what you might get from a smart watch. I mean, how is it different what you're looking at from, you say, like, these rings and so forth, they're measuring whether you're moving or not. What are you doing that's different? Physically observing people sleeping in a lab, is that the difference? So when people come into the sleep lab, or I should say, we're doing this a lot in people's homes these days. My current studies are almost all happening in people's homes now where we're monitoring their brain activities, so they're EEG. One of things that's important differentiator is all the wearable devices, they're not actually measuring
也许是时候和某人谈谈了，特别是如果它真的对某人的功能能力产生了负面影响。通常当人们来诊所看我时，我说，你失眠多久了？他们说已经20年了。已经10年了。我会说，那你为什么不早点寻求帮助？
sleep. They're measuring movement, heart rates, skin temperature, depending on what sensors they contain. And they're using that information to estimate sleep and wakefulness. The only way you can actually measure sleep directly is by measuring brain activity. And so when people come to the sleep lab or if we study them in the home, we're getting them wired up with all these electrodes to measure direct brain activity as a just more reliable indicator of what is going on with their sleep. Most people experience periods of poor sleep, at least occasionally. How can you tell the difference between a minor sleep problem and one where you should be seeking help? Probably the biggest factor is how long it's been going on.
对。所以我说，你不必在一周后就寻求帮助。但如果已经一个月、两个月、三个月了，可能就是时候了。现在，随着年龄的增长，人们的昼夜节律会自然改变吗？我的意思是，我自己也在变老，我可以告诉你，我过去讨厌在早上七点、六点起床。现在，你知道，那对我来说是一个正常的时间。我只是想知道，这常见吗？人们的节律会随着年龄增长而改变吗？绝对会。我们所有人，平均而言，在青春期期间昼夜节律会有两到三个小时的延迟。事实上，有些人甚至认为这是青春期的标志，即你的昼夜节律，我们称之为昼夜节律的延迟。所以青少年因为这种转变而自然倾向于成为夜猫子。这导致了，很多人熟悉美国许多学区推动高中开学时间推迟的情况，这是因为这个原因，他们的昼夜节律与早上的学校开学时间之间存在生物学上的不匹配。
I mean, like you said, we all have bouts of insomnia here and there. Sometimes I'll ask when I'm talking to an audience, I'll say, raise your hand if you've never had a bad night asleep. And no one ever raises their hand. Right. And so, you know, definitely I want to normalize that some bad nights here and there are completely normal. But when it's going on for weeks, turning into some months, and it's just not going away.
大多数人在20岁出头到中期会再次稍微提前，尽管有些人会终身保持夜猫子。然后正是你所描述的，金，在生命后期有一种提前我们节律的倾向。所以我们的节律在生命后期往往会提前。并不是每个人都这样，但我们确实越老越倾向于成为早起的人。
Maybe it's time to talk with someone about it, especially if it's really having a negative impact on someone's ability to function. Oftentimes when people come to see me in clinic, and I say, how long have you had insomnia? So it's been 20 years. It's been 10 years. And I'll say, well, why didn't you seek help sooner for this?
总的来说，你对我们的听众有什么建议来确保他们有健康的睡眠习惯吗？我一直在努力传达的最重要的事情之一就是把睡眠作为优先事项。我的意思是，人们生活忙碌，睡眠往往是日程中被挤掉的事情。所以我认为这是一个把睡眠作为优先事项的问题。我的意思是，没有人想因为没有睡好而日复一日地感到疲倦。所以把它作为优先事项。所以你至少给自己足够的时间在床上以获得睡眠的机会。我推荐的其他一些作为良好起点的建议是规律性。
Right. And so I'd say, like, you don't have to seek help me, be after a week. But if it's been a month, two months, three months, it's probably time. Now, do people's circadian rhythms change naturally as we get older? I mean, I'm getting older myself and I can tell you I used to hate to get up at, you know, seven o'clock, six o'clock in the morning. And now that's, you know, that's a normal time for me. And I'm just wondering, is that common? Does that happen for people that their rhythms will change as they age? Absolutely. We all have, on average, a two to three hours.
昼夜节律喜欢规律性。所以有时我和人们交谈，他们的睡眠时间表到处都是。你知道，一晚他们10点上床，下一晚是凌晨1点，然后是11点，然后是9点。当我们的时间表变化很大时，我们的节律很难真正设定
shift later in our circadian rhythms during puberty. In fact, some people have even argued this is a marker of puberty, is that your circadian rhythms, we say it's a delay in our circadian rhythms. And so teens just have a natural tendency to be night owls because of this shift. And this has led to, a lot of people are familiar with kind of the push of a lot of school districts around the US to make high school start times later. it's because of this, there's a biological mismatch between their circadian rhythm
到一个好的节律。所以保持一个规律的时间表。可能我推荐最多的另一件事是不要追逐睡眠。我的意思是，睡眠是那种事情，当然，我们越努力让它发生，
and their early school start times. The majority of people by early to mid-20s will have shifted somewhat earlier again, although some people will remain lifelong night owls. And then exactly what you're describing, Kim, is later in life there's a tendency to advance our rhythms. So our rhythms tend to shift earlier later in life. and not everyone, but we do have a greater tendency to be mourning people the older weekend.
它发生的可能性就越小，我的病人说这是失眠最令人沮丧的事情之一，因为他们越努力睡得更好，他们的睡眠实际上就越差。所以当人们发现自己躺在床上无法入睡时，最糟糕的事情之一就是躺在那里翻来覆去很长时间。这令人沮丧，令人焦虑，实际上只会让睡眠变得更困难。所以我总是建议，如果人们发现自己躺在床上，翻来覆去，试图入睡，
Broadly speaking, do you have advice for our listeners to make sure that they've got healthy sleep habits? One of the biggest things I'm always trying to communicate is just making sleep a priority. I mean, people live busy lives and often sleep is the thing that gets squeezed out of their schedule. And so I think it's a matter of making sleep a priority. I mean, no one wants to live life feeling tired day after day because they're not getting a good night of sleep. So making it a priority. So you're at least giving yourself enough time in bed to get opportunity for sleep. Some of the other things I recommend as kind of a good starting point are regularity.
就是休息一下，起床，理想情况下去另一个房间，从事放松但不过度刺激的活动，直到你觉得准备好再次入睡，但只是为了避免在床上翻来覆去。如果你在半夜起床，有什么你应该做或不应该做的事情吗？它应该是放松的，但不是，我常说，有时人们会告诉我，
are circadian rhythms like regularity. And so sometimes I talk with people and there's sleep schedules all over the place. You know, one night they're going to bed at 10, the next night it's one in the morning, then it's 11, and then it's 9. And when our schedules are widely variable, it's hard for our rhythms to get really set
嗯，我起床打开电视。我说的下一句话是，你在看什么？因为我无法告诉你有多少人告诉我他们在晚上睡不着时看新闻。哦，不。完全正确。我说，当你看完新闻时，你觉得世界一切都好，你可以放松去睡觉吗？或者如果人们要拿起什么东西来读。我说，嗯，不要读悬疑谋杀小说，因为那样你会沉迷其中，不想睡觉。但它也不需要很无聊。回到我们过去有电话簿的时候，我会告诉，我有时有客户说，哦，我睡不着时读电话簿。我会说，那听起来太可怕了。所以它应该是愉快的、放松的，但不是刺激的。
to anyone one good rhythm. So keeping a regular schedule. And probably the other thing I recommend the most common is not to chase sleep. And what I mean by that is, sleep is one of those things that, of course, the harder we try to make it happen,
那么是什么让你进入睡眠研究领域的？这是为了你自己吗？你有睡眠问题吗？不，实际上，人们经常问我这个问题。我常说，你知道，我不是什么运动员，但如果睡觉是一项奥林匹克运动，我想我可以拿奖牌。我通常是一个睡得很好的人。
the less likely it is to actually happen, which my patients say is one of the most frustrating things about having insomnia is that the more they try to sleep better, the worse their sleep actually gets. And so when people find themselves in bed unable to sleep, one of the worst things to do is to just lie there tossing and turning for long periods of time. It's frustrating, it's anxiety provoking, and it actually just makes it harder to sleep. So I always recommend if people find themselves in bed, tossing and turning, trying to sleep,
这实际上归结为我的本科时光。我现在工作的大学，宾大，实际上是我上大学的地方，在我大四那年，我上了一门关于睡眠和昼夜节律的课。我就被迷住了。我只是，我发现这个话题太有趣了。我的意思是，那时，我们知道的比现在少得多。从那时起我们已经走了很长一段路。
is to take a break, is to get up, ideally go to a whole other room, and engage in relaxing but not overly stimulating activities, until you feel ready to sleep again, but just to avoid those long periods of tossing and turning in bed. And if you get up in the middle of the night, are there certain things that you should or shouldn't do? It should be relaxing, but not, I often say, sometimes people will tell me,
但在我毕业后，我在去读研究生之前，设法在宾大的睡眠实验室找到了一份研究助理的工作。所以这确实巩固了我的兴趣。所以我总是告诉我的本科生，他们说，你永远不知道一门课会在你的兴趣方面激发什么不同。我当然就是一个例子。那么接下来是什么？我的意思是，你研究睡眠已经有一段时间了。我的意思是，你还在试图回答什么问题？你现在在做什么？睡眠和心理健康的整个交叉领域在20世纪80年代、90年代是一个非常热门的研究领域。它在某种程度上消亡了，因为意义和徒劳，有很多死胡同。我试图提出的观点是，我们的研究工具和技术现在好多了，时机确实成熟了，可以重振这个研究领域。甚至有很多低垂的果实我们可以做，利用新技术，利用这些技术变革。我的意思是，我们现在可以给人们戴上设备，或者给人们设备来测量他们家里的脑电图，持续数周。我的意思是，我们拥有的工具比那时多得多。而且我认为现在也是，睡眠在这些天是一个非常受欢迎的文化话题。我也认为时机成熟了，可以了解我们如何将对睡眠的理解纳入常规心理健康护理。所以我一直在试图与人们谈论你如何将以睡眠为重点的评估和治疗纳入你的实践，因为有太多的机会可以做到这一点，并真正改善人们的生活。好吧，格曼博士，我想感谢您今天参加我的节目。这非常有趣，我希望对我们的一些听众有所帮助。
well, I get up and I turn on the TV. I say, the very next thing I say, well, what are you watching? Because I can't tell you how many people have told me they watch the news when they can't sleep at night. Oh, no. Exactly. I say, and when you're done watching the news, do you feel like all is well with the world and you can relax and go to sleep? Or if people are going to pick up something to read. I say, well, don't read a suspenseful murder novel because then you're going to get sucked into it and not want to go to sleep. But it doesn't need to be boring either. Back when we used to have phone books, I would tell, I have clients sometimes say, oh, I read the phone book when I can't sleep. And I would say, that sounds horrible. And so it should be enjoyable. relaxing, but not stimulating.
这是我的荣幸。感谢邀请我参加。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology 上找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何您获取播客的地方。如果您喜欢您所听到的，请关注我们并留下评论。如果您对未来的节目有意见或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至 Speaking of Psychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·威纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。
So what got you into the field of sleep research? Was this me search for you? Do you have sleep problems? No, actually, people ask me that a lot. And I often say, you know, I'm not much of an athlete, but if sleeping were an Olympic sport, I think I could meddle. I'm generally a really good sleeper.
感谢您的收听。美国心理学会。我是金·米尔斯。嘿，大家好。我是凯莉·克拉克森（Kelly Clarkson），与 Wayfair 合作。有没有在网上订购过家具，想知道“如果……会怎样”？比如，如果它不耐用怎么办？那张沙发才用了四天。
It actually came down to my undergraduate time. The university where I work now, Penn, is actually where I went to college. and my senior year, I took a class on sleep and circadian rhythms. And I was hooked. I just, I found the topic to be so interesting. I mean, back then, we knew a lot less than we know now. We've come quite a long way since then.
你应该从 Wayfair 订购。在 Wayfair，没有“如果”。只有你喜欢的风格和你可以信赖的质量。访问 Wayfair.ca。Wayfair，每种风格，每个家。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
But then after I graduated, I managed to get a job as a research assistant in the sleep lab here at Penn before going on to graduate school. And so that really solidified my interest. And so I always tell my undergraduate students, they say, you never know what difference is, what a single class is going to spark in terms of your interest. And I'm certainly an example of that. So what's next? I mean, you've been studying sleep now for quite a while. I mean, what are the questions that you're still trying to answer? What are you working on now? The whole intersection of sleep and mental health was a very hot area of research in the 1980s, kind of 1990s. And it kind of died off to a certain extent because significant and vain, there were a lot of dead ends that hit. The case I'm trying to make is that our research tools and techniques are so much better now that the time is really ripe to kind of reinvigorate this. area of research. And there's even just a lot of low-hanging fruit that we can be doing that taps into a newer techniques, that taps into these changes of technology. I mean, the fact that we can now put devices on people, or give people devices to measure EEG in their home for
但在我毕业后，我成功在宾大的睡眠实验室找到了一份研究助理的工作，之后才去读的研究生。那段经历真正巩固了我的兴趣。所以我总是告诉我的本科生，你永远不知道一门课会如何激发你的兴趣。我就是一个很好的例子。那么接下来呢？你研究睡眠已经有一段时间了。你还在试图回答哪些问题？你现在在研究什么？睡眠与心理健康的交叉领域在20世纪80年代和90年代是一个非常热门的研究领域。但后来在某种程度上它逐渐沉寂了，因为当时遇到了很多死胡同。我试图证明的是，我们现在的研究工具和技术已经先进多了，现在正是重振这一研究领域的绝佳时机。有很多唾手可得的研究机会，我们可以利用新技术和科技的进步。比如，我们现在可以给人们佩戴设备，或者让他们在家中使用设备来测量脑电图，持续数周之久。
weeks on end. I mean, we just have so many tools that we did not have back then. And I think Now it's also, sleep is such a popular cultural topic these days. I also think the time is right to understand how can we incorporate an understanding of sleep into routine mental health care. And so I'm always trying to kind of talk with people about how can you be incorporating sleep focused assessment and treatment into your practice because there's just so many opportunities to do that and really improve people's lives. Well, Dr. German, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been very interesting and I hope helpful to some of our listeners.
我们拥有的工具比过去多得多。而且我认为，现在睡眠是一个非常热门的文化话题。我也认为，现在是时候去了解如何将睡眠知识融入到常规的心理健康护理中了。所以我一直在与人们探讨如何将以睡眠为重点的评估和治疗纳入到他们的实践中，因为这方面有很多机会，可以真正改善人们的生活。好的，格曼博士，感谢您今天参加我们的节目。这次谈话非常有趣，希望对我们的听众有所帮助。
It's been my pleasure. Thanks for having me on. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology. Or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at AP. p.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman.
这是我的荣幸。谢谢邀请我参加。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology 上找到《心理学谈话》往期节目，也可以在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何您收听播客的地方找到我们。如果您喜欢我们的节目，请关注我们并留下评论。如果您对未来的节目有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 Speaking of Psychology at AP.p.org。《心理学谈话》由李·威纳曼制作。
Thank you for listening. The American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Hey, y'all. It's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair. Ever order furniture online and wonder what if? Like, what if it doesn't hold up? That sofa was four days old.
感谢您的收听。美国心理学会。我是金·米尔斯。嘿，大家好。我是凯莉·克拉克森，为您介绍 Wayfair。有没有在网上订购过家具，然后担心“万一呢”？比如，万一它不耐用怎么办？那张沙发才用了四天。
You should have ordered from Wayfair. With Wayfair, there's no what if. Just style you love and quality you can trust. Visit Wayfair.ca.ca. Wayfair, every style, every home. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你应该从 Wayfair 订购。在 Wayfair，没有“万一”。只有你喜欢的风格和值得信赖的品质。请访问 Wayfair.ca。Wayfair，适合各种风格，适合每个家庭。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。